-Our next guest is an
Emmy-winning actress
you know from shows
like "Designing Women,"
"Frasier," "Fargo,"
and "Watchmen."
She stars in "Hacks," which is
streaming now on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-You have to be
so much more than good.
And even if you're great
and lucky, you still have to
work really (bleep) hard.
And even that is not enough!
You have to scratch and claw
and it never (bleep) ends.
And it doesn't get better.
It just gets harder.
So don't complain to me
that I am making your life hard.
You don't even know
what that means.
[ Helicopter blades thrumming
Oh, good, my ride's here.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back
to the show Jean Smart!
How are you, Jean?
-[ Laughing ]
I am good. How are you, Seth
-I'm wonderful.
It's always so good to see you
Now, you play a character
named Debra Vance in the show,
and I can't help but noticin
the very large
street sign behind you.
-Really?
-[ Laughing ]
-I didn't --
I didn't think --
Really? It's a --
I guess it's sort of --
Yeah, I guess
it's sort of large.
[ Laughing ]
I don't know where it came from.
-Very, very subtle promotion
I tip my cap, Jean.
-[ Smacks table ]
[ Laughter ]
I like this look on you,
by the way.
This casual --
-Yeah, right?
-It suits you. It really does.
-Yeah, you know,
this is the real me.
There's no reason to hide
behind a suit anymore.
-Never again.
-This is a wonderful show.
You play a comedian
who's been doing a show
on the Strip in Vegas
for a very long time
who has a stale act and brings
a younger comedian in...
-[ Laughing ]
-...to help her out.
And the other actor -- I hop
I'm saying her last name right
Hannah Einbinder?
Is that right?
-Einbinder, yes.
I think she made that up.
-[ Laughs ] It does sound like
a made-up name.
-Yeah.
-Do you guys enjoy
working together
as much as it seems on-screen?
-More so, yeah.
We laugh all day long.
I'm very, very
impressed with her.
I was a little
intimidated at first,
'cause she's actually
been doing stand-up
professionally since college
But no, she's a sweetheart
This is basically
her first show.
I mean, she's just a natural
When we first started working,
she was very sweet.
And she came up to me
one day, and she said,
"I really want to thank you,
'cause I heard that you really
went to bat for me
with the producers."
And I said, "I did, absolutely
You were my first choice.
I saw tapes and had audition
with several actresses.
And I was -- You know,
you were the one.
I was like, "In fact,
I told the producers
that if they didn't hire you
I wasn't gonna do the show."
And she said, "Really?"
I said, "No!"
-[ Laughing ]
-What are you, nuts?! [ Laughs ]
-See? You're built to play
a stand-up comedian.
-Terrible.
I hesitated for just a second,
'cause I thought,
"Oh no, should I say that?
I though, "Ah, she's a comedian.
She'll be fine."
-Do you like playing
a stand-up comedian?
You said maybe
it was intimidating
doing it in front of a stand-up,
but you certainly seemed
like a natural.
-Oh, it's so much fun.
Of course, I didn't have
a real audience.
I mean, I had people who wer
paid to laugh, so, you know.
It's a little bit different,
as you well know.
-Well, NBC won't even pay
for people to be here and laugh.
-[ Laughing ]
-That'd be nice. [ Laughs
I heard that you were a fa
of Phyllis Diller's,
and you can count me
as one, too.
You dressed up
as Phyllis Diller.
How old were you when you were
dressing up like Phyllis Diller?
-I believe I was 11.
-Okay.
-And I just thought that
she was just the funniest thin
I had ever seen, and she looke
like she was having so much fun.
And I thought,
"Yeah, that looks cool.
I'd like to do that."
And so, I dressed up as he
at a Halloween party.
-Did people know
who the 11-year-old
dressed like Phyllis Dille
was trying to be?
-[ Laughs ] I don't remember
Not everybody, no.
I think they just thought
I was going through
a phase of some kind.
-There's not a ton
of intimate scenes in this show,
but there is still
an intimacy coordinator on set
I feel this is very common now
and a step
in the right direction.
How have you enjoyed working
with your intimacy coordinator
-Well, see, that's the thing -
there isn't --
Well, Hannah has a scene
that's a little steamy,
but I certainly didn't think
I was gonna be getting a cal
from the intimacy coach.
-Oh, it's a coach.
-Yeah.
The night before a scene
where I kiss a man,
or he kisses me --
that was it --
I get an email
from the intimacy coach
telling me that she's gonna be
on the set tomorrow
just to make sure
that everybody's comfortable
And I said,
"Well, now I'm uncomfortable
I wasn't uncomfortable before.
Not your fault," I said,
"but now I feel like a jerk.
You're gonna be sitting
there watching us slow dance
and then he kisses me.
Oh, God, I thought
it was so weird.
And she said,
"Well, everybody does it now
because it's very P.C."
And I guess lawsuits
and things like that, so -
-Yeah, it seems like
better to have than not.
-Yeah. Well, I guess -- Yeah
You don't want something
to come up.
Well, I didn't mean like that,
but something to happen
that no one was expecting.
But I came home,
and I told my husband
about the intimacy coach,
and he went off
on this whole thing
about -- [ Laughs ]
Can you imagine
if you went to the set
and Bear Bryant
was your intimacy coach?
With the chart and everything?
You know, "We're gonna
fake out the nipple
and do a fumble-rooski
around the left flank!"
Oh, my God, I was dying.
-[ Laughs ]
-That would be
a great "SNL" sketch.
-Speaking of, I'm gonna ask yo
about an "SNL" sketch.
We're gonna be back
in one minute
with more from Jean Smart.